what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to um men still hate
women so just being part of the
manosphere i thought it'd be interesting
to see
um some people outside of the
manosphere's perspective i'm assuming
this is just like because of the
manosphere but i could be wrong
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos while you're
at it
go follow my instagram it's just pearly
things but instead of an s
at the end it's a z you're famous i
don't care how old you are
you don't take pictures of yourself
in custody after being found guilty
afraid and look
that's the walker the hard times
throughout this trial
it works in a jail cell
thank god my barristers brendan kelly on
stephen
my solicitors joe mcveigh and kevin
winters of krw law
we're grateful to the jury for reaching
what was a common
not once but twice correct both feet
hello everybody i hope you're all well
so
today's video is going to be all about
why
men hate women okay this is just a pause
women that tend to have this belief
system
um you know misogyny like the patriarchy
they tend to be like cute
because they tend to like get treated
like an option
by the top 20 of men because as you guys
know 20 of men have sexual access to 80
of women and that is probably what i
put her in maybe i would give her like a
seven still
they never stopped from the title this
video does sound like it's going to be
very
antagonizing and it kind of is i'm
mostly going to be talking about
modern forms of misogyny in the 21st
century
and why we do still need feminism
unfortunately a lot of people are under
the impression
both men and women that we don't need
feminism
anymore that feminism is basically
rendered useless in the 21st century
because of how far
women's rights have come but i want to
debunk this myth and just set a few
points and this is literally just a few
out of
many of why we okay so i'm 24
and genuinely i haven't
personally been helped by feminism
in my lifetime now i'm sure there's
policies that i'd benefit from that
happened before i was alive
but in this lifetime
hasn't helped me i've never needed an
abortion because they're going to say
abortion rights
um i've never
gone to like purchase birth control
like i could afford it so it's not
we do still need feminism in the 21st
century and
i am more than aware that women's rights
have come forward absolute leaps and
bounds in this country
i am very grateful and fortunate to live
in a country
where women's rights have progressed so
much compared to other countries
but just because women's rights have
progressed so much in this country
doesn't mean we could not and should not
point out problems which still
exist within the patriarchy and i'm also
more than aware that this does not
apply to every single man that exists
but i think not only just in men but in
women as well in all of us really
misogyny has been so ingrained into our
heads from such a young age that it is
really really difficult to
unlearn misogynistic habits even i
still to this day find myself being
internally misogynistic
i do think most women will agree with me
on this point that in my whole lifetime
my whole 22 years of being alive on this
planet
i have only met three
straight men who aren't misogynistic
in any way i don't think which is always
what three men
okay this is
this is what bothers me you pick
who you interact with and who you hang
out with i understand there's work
in school right okay that that's one sec
what's one set of people
but you cannot say that 100 of men
and the people you work with are
misogynistic it's the people that you
choose to interact with
you are what you attract this confused
me because there's not the whole
point of being a straight man that
you're meant to like women
so that is what i'm going to be doing in
today's video i'm going to be talking
about how
misogyny manifests itself in different
ways in the 21st century
and how a lot of people tend to not
notice that it's misogyny i've got
four examples that i'm using today there
is also going to be a part two to this
video where i'm talking all about
internalized misogyny so if you aren't
subscribed
make sure you're that what women say
about me
because this is what always happens if i
disagree with most women on
a topic they'll say i'm i have
internalized misogyny
which doesn't even make sense
so the first example we have is [ __ ]
shaming this is not anything new that's
been spoken about before
everyone knows that there is a huge
double standard when it comes to
promiscuity in men
versus promiscuity in women there is yep
there is
we've all heard of it before but i am
just going to quickly explain it for the
sake of this video
basically when a man is promiscuous and
sleeps around they are seen as a stud
and a player and
in particular they are seen as extremely
masculine by
other men and meanwhiles if a woman is
promiscuous and
sleeps around they are seen as a [ __ ] or
[ __ ]
in some cases even dirty used goods
guys don't want to go there with a girl
that's easy etc
and already we can see how these double
standards can actually be harmful
towards
men as well because so many men
a majority of men i think put their self
value into how much sex they have and
how much women find them attractive
because there is this huge pressure okay
but you have to realize
that it's the women's
fault that there is this double standard
because women want to sleep with men who
slept with a lot of women
if women did not want to sleep with men
that slept with a lot of women
this double standard wouldn't exist and
i think it's better to be honest about
the double standard where if you sleep
with a lot of people
less people will want to date you at
least that's honest
instead of what telling society to
change there's evolutionary reasons why
we feel the way we feel
like the evolutionary reason behind it
is a man doesn't want to raise another
man's kid so if a woman slept with a lot
of guys
historically like you you wouldn't know
if it's yours you can't ensure paternity
and that's just how it is it's not fair
but
neither is life to get laid and be
sexually active
and for men that don't have a lot of sex
and are very sexually active it can lead
to
very low self-esteem and a very warped
perception of themselves yeah i'm pretty
convinced that this whole
the more women you sleep with the more
masculine you are i am pretty sure
led to the whole incel movement and that
big
steaming hot pile of [ __ ] that i will
cover another day
that's okay i think insults come from
women not wanting
to sleep with the guys and so
and the guys genuinely don't generally
don't put themselves in a position where
women want to sleep with them anyway so
see i'm just into like taking
responsibility for your own world
like it's your own fault it's the
in-cell's fault but
i'm not going to go around telling
society to change i'm wrong there are
actually people out there who
are turned off by men who are
particularly promiscuous
or sleep around or very sexually active
but it really isn't that many
especially compared to how many men are
turned off by women who are very
sexually active and promiscuous
sorry quick break i had to take my uh
but you i bet she slept around that's
probably why
she thinks this slips out because
they're making my forehead look
absolutely gigantic
anyways i know so many women who would
happily date men with
high body counts and they genuinely do
not care i know girls in my personal
life whose boyfriend's body counts are
100 plus and they literally did not care
or the only part they cared about was
that they would get the beat and delete
treatment
and as i said earlier with women it is a
completely different story if you are
promiscuous you are seen as a [ __ ] or
[ __ ]
the town bike easy not wife material
etc the list goes on and it's not just
men who [ __ ] shame women
women [ __ ] shame women too i used to do
it when i was younger and that's really
really embarrassing to even think about
but also it's not just well women's
watching women
as a way to be more attractive to men so
she probably did that so
she could say oh that girl sleeps with
everyone
i don't sleep with anyone i need
everyone therefore i'm a better
mate option the amount of people that
women sleep with that they get shamed
for is
how long they wait to sleep with someone
for example someone could
have what they consider a low body count
but if they've perhaps had a few one
night stands or they slept with someone
after a first date oh that's [ __ ]
women are slut-shamed for their kinks if
they like consensual rough sex
bdsm out of the norm kinks they're
either letting men disrespect them or
they have no respect for themselves
apparently
women are even slut-shamed for the way
they dress
yes some outfits can be considered
[ __ ]
i have no idea how an outfit can show
how
sexually promiscuous you are to be
honest another problem really well
because girls that are more comfortable
showing their body like i guarantee if
you did a study
measuring promiscuity and girls taking
off their clothes
like it doesn't are wearing [ __ ] or
outfits it doesn't take a genius to know
that the girls that seek that attention
and male validation
tend to sleep with more guys related to
slut-shaming is leaking sex and
nudes more often than not it is a man
leaking a picture or a video of a woman
and more often than not rather than the
man being held responsible
for leaking a video or a picture which
they weren't supposed to which they were
trusted with etc
the woman is criticized for sending it
in the first place
okay but this this is the way i look at
the world
you take responsibility for your world
so if you want to have
a zero chance that any of your nudes get
leaked
ever don't send them because
you you can't control what the guy does
but you can control what you do
and do i think it's terrible behavior
for the guy to do that
yeah of course absolutely but he has
every
interest like if he shares a nude with
someone
he's gonna look cool so he has every
vested interest in sharing that
and so if you guys end on bad terms or
something
you have no idea how that's gonna play
out you shouldn't have sent that kind of
picture or video anyway if you knew the
risk blah blah blah
as far as i'm aware most women only send
pictures and videos to people that they
genuinely trust
so they never send it not always i know
girls will send it to damn near anyone
thinking that the person would leak it
or send it on etc
also some of the time men will literally
coerce these pictures
and pressure these women to send
pictures to them when you're sending
i will say that's true there's a lot of
guys
i think there's a lot of girls that
really need to be trained on how to say
no to things because
i've noticed that a lot of girls end up
doing things that they don't want to do
because like the guy just keeps
pressuring them and pressuring them and
pressuring them
videos and pictures yeah you know the
risk but you genuinely trust the person
that you are sending them to
and you genuinely think they wouldn't do
that to you so the man completely
violates the woman's trust
embarrasses her and humiliates her and
somehow it's the woman's fault it's like
blaming someone for getting hit by a car
when crossing the road using a zebra
crossing for example
a car driving through a zebra crossing
when a pedestrian is going across it
is illegal the same way that leaking sex
and nudes is also illegal
but there is still that risk when you
use a zebra crossing that a car or a bus
can just go zooming past and hit you
but if that does happen who do you blame
the driver who should have been
following the law
or the person who took the risk and
crossed the road another example of [ __ ]
shaming is when men
cheat on their wives and have affairs
with other women etc
it's often the mistress that gets the
brunt of the anger and not the cheating
husband
not that much of the anger is directed
towards the cheating husband i don't
know
tiger woods i literally remember when i
was a kid him apologizing to the public
but i think the issue is that when a
man's found cheating
more women want him so again that's
that's
girls it's just human nature
um but is the mistress in the wrong too
hell yeah absolutely if you sleep with a
married man knowingly
the only person who has the loyalties in
this situation
the person who is literally married
cheating on their wife
there are so many examples of this
happening in celebrity and influencer
culture but i will just list a few
more recently there was some pictures of
dominic west and lily james
which were taken by paparazzi which were
posted on twitter when they were in
italy
there wasn't any pictures of them like
explicitly kissing each other but they
were definitely very
cozy and because dominic west is a
married man
it was extremely inappropriate but when
this all came out it wasn't dominic west
the married man that was trending on
twitter it was lily james and everyone
calling her a [ __ ]
everyone was bad-mouthing lily james the
single woman
not dominic west the married man and now
i'm not trying to advocate to
go for married men or to become a
mistress because to be honest i think
most you know what i think all women can
do better than a married man to be
honest but it's very common when affairs
are
revealed that the wife will go after the
mistress
rather than her cheating husband another
well a lot of times they want to stay
with the cheating husband
so they have to get rid of the mistress
a very well-known example of this was
the jordan
woods and tristan no jordan woods was so
in the wrong
that was a terrible thing to do they
gave her everything
and she took advantage of the situation
that
no no sympathy thompson situation
this does slightly differ because jordan
woods did have loyalties to the family
you know so both of them were in the
wrong but people went in
so hard on jordan woods and khloe
kardashian even took
back her cheating i can't remember if it
was a boyfriend or a husband
but she took him back and didn't forgive
jordan and i'm pretty sure she called
her fat
as well it's just like you can't forgive
one that's not true
she forgave jordan she said it in the
last interview and then not
forgive the other and what's even more
as it gets about [ __ ] shaming is
if you are very sexually active and you
have a lot of casual sex and you're very
promiscuous you're considered a [ __ ] but
if you're a virgin
you're considered prude and boring so
either way you literally cannot win
and like i've said before the term [ __ ]
is not just used by men it is very often
used by women as well
i remember there was this weird trend
like i believe it was about 10
years ago i'm pretty sure i made one as
well which is so embarrassing to think
about and it was people holding up
placards
saying like hey girl did you know your
scar
goes over your ass or something like
that and it was loads of girls doing it
2012 was a wild time but like i said
girls would do that
to fight competition for the guys that's
why they do it
i will elaborate more on internalized
misogyny in the second part
to this video personally i don't think
there is any such thing
as a [ __ ] i think the term [ __ ] has been
weaponized against women to shame them
for their sexual activity
when we all know that your sexual
activity does not make any difference to
your worth as a person
and most of us know that regardless of
whether you fit
the term [ __ ] or not men and women will
use that insult and throw it in your
face
it's a very common insult to use when
you turn down a man they'll call you a
fat
[ __ ] oh my god guys so do that that's
happened to me before well i tell a guy
no
and then he calls me a [ __ ] guys do that
slag etc
literally happened to me the other day a
majority of misogyny is rooted in
jealousy
and a majority of men's misogyny is
rooted in the fact that they can't
get the women that they want so they
will throw misogynistic terms like [ __ ]
and slag in your face just because they
feel emasculated
now i'm going to leave it at that when
it comes to [ __ ] shaming i know there is
so much more to say so i will link down
below a few articles
which i use to research for this and
some more if you guys want to know more
about it but obviously
i want to try and cover as many things
as i can in this video
treatment of sex workers
i'm following up with [ __ ] shaming with
treatment of
sex workers or rather the mistreatment
of sex workers
because the two very much go hand in
hand
the term sex worker is really an
umbrella term for a broad amount of jobs
it can be anything from
cam girls only fan girls strippers
prostitutes
porn stars etc and there is an extremely
long history of
men mistreating sex workers despite them
being their main consumers
and also if you guys didn't know sex
work is one of the only
industries that is mostly female
dominated
women get paid the most women get the
most work
etc now i'm not going to be focusing on
porn stars or strippers
or prostitutes today if you guys want to
know more about
legalization when it comes to
prostitution
i recommend checking out my video about
only fans and sex work we all know
that men mistreat those women despite
them being their largest consumers
but a more modern more
recent phenomenon has been the treatment
of
only fans workers online it's something
which is very new and it's something
which i find very interesting so i'm
going to talk about it the biggest
critics of sex workers surprisingly or i
guess unsurprisingly
is in cells i find really interesting
because
oh my gosh this is so true are men
who i agree with you are so desperate
to have an intimate relationship with a
woman and to have sex with her
that they literally hate every single
woman that rejects them so you think
that they would actually
like sex workers because sex workers are
providing them with the opportunity
to have sex but no they hate them
because they hate any woman
ever and especially they hate women who
manage to profit
from their attractiveness if you guys
don't know what only fans is well i
think it pisses a lot of guys off where
they have to work so hard for their
money and these girls can just be pretty
and make a ton of money it is a
subscription website where people will
pay
a certain amount a month to access
exclusive content
and because only fans has very relaxed
rules and regulations it is mostly used
by sex workers in particular female sex
workers
and they can post really anything on
their compose lingerie photos
videos tapes pictures nudes
etc and the top only fans creators
make bank and by bank i
mean bank i'm talking some of these
girls are making upwards of ten
thousand dollars a month from only fans
they're doing amazing
and because of the extremely negative
stigma that only fans and sex work in
general
has these women are very vocal about how
much they earn
almost as a way to be like hey i'm doing
this for a reason by the way like how
much money i'm making
or hey but like what at what cost at the
cost of your soul
i mean some people can be bought to do
anything and i understand like the
tempting allure of only fans
but if you're gonna do only fans you
can't complain about the cost
if you're getting easy money don't
complain when less
guys want to date you like
it's fine if that's what you want to do
i'm not someone that's going to
really care what you do but at the end
of the day i would never tell my
daughter to do it
and you create your own world
so if people treat you this way it's
because you sold your soul
for money and it's trying to slag me off
for doing sex work like how much money
i'm making up yours
i don't really blame them for this to be
honest and of course with
any line of sex work i do recommend that
women who do want to do it
make sure you actually think through the
repercussions of
what you're going to do and make sure
it's actually something that you
want to do and not just something where
you think that you're gonna make quick
money out of it but only fans
is one of the safest and least
exploitative
forms of sex work out there these women
are in complete control of what
content they create and distribute it is
extremely difficult to be exploited on
only fans because you are your own boss
unlike other forms of sex work such as
stripping porn and prostitution where it
is very very easy
to be exploited if anything we should be
celebrating only
fans because it is one of the safest and
least exploitative
forms of sex work but unfortunately a
lot of people
mostly men get extremely heated over the
topic
it's either only fans girls have it easy
they don't deserve
the money they're making they sell i
hate the word don't deserve
because it's
i think you deserve what you get ninety
percent of the time they're nudes for x
amount of money that's disgusting
they're [ __ ] their fathers should be
ashamed of themselves they're never
gonna get a boyfriend because i'd never
date someone with an only fans
their mentions will literally be full of
men abusing them
just because they're sex workers yeah
but their mentions are also
full of guys gassing them up you know
you know
like you know what the territory comes
with so i i don't have a lot of sympathy
for someone that signs up for something
and then there's consequences
very recently one woman i didn't manage
to grab her twitter handle so if anyone
knows it then please leave a comment so
i can stick it in the description
she posted on twitter that she had
bought her first ever apartment
using money she made from only fans and
the tweet gained quite a lot of
attention i believe it had around 50 to
100 000 likes
and basically a load of men reported her
account so it got deleted
just because they were so human that a
woman
managed to make enough money to buy an
apartment from only fans earnings are
you being serious
grow up also another thing i want to
tackle is the whole
i would never date someone with an only
fans this may be a controversial opinion
i don't think so there is nothing wrong
if you don't want to date a sex worker
if that's something that you would
not prefer to do that's fine but what
isn't
fine is getting all up in sex workers
mentioned saying oh i could never date a
sex worker that's disgusting
because like who asked also i don't
think she'd ever date you
anyway i mean did you really ever have a
chance with this sex worker let's be
real probably not
and another thing yeah no that's that's
real
i'll there's a lot of guys that'll say
on my channel i would never date this i
would never date that
but i'll see their profile pictures and
i'm thinking dude what other options you
got
[Music]
but no i don't see any problem if you
don't want to date someone but i don't
really understand people that go out of
their way
to bully these girls
but i just don't care i really don't
care what other people do
thing these men who will abuse
and tweet sex workers all the time
because they hate sex workers that their
disappointments
their fathers should be ashamed of them
they don't deserve the money they earn
etc
if you are so bothered by sex workers if
genuinely if women making money on only
fans
boils your blood so much you do realize
the mute button exists
you can literally just mute them and you
and it won't bother you
ever again and if i'm gonna be
completely honest obviously i think
hatred towards sex workers is deeply
rooted in misogyny but
mostly i think it's rooted in jealousy i
think that these men are extremely
jealous that they cannot profit off
their bodies the same way that women can
and they can't deal with just one
industry if i
ask most men if they would sell their
bodies for a certain amount of money
most guys say yeah
that is female dominated and also i
don't think they can deal with the fact
that only fans has finally
given women the option to do sex work
without being
exploited or abused and also they're
probably attracted to them on top of
that
so it's all those factors combined to be
honest
the false rape accusation oh no
so now i'm going to be talking about the
false
rape accusation argument and i know some
of you guys going to say
rape is not just something which affects
women and i'm more than aware of that
but i'm just going to read out some
statistics for you guys
91 of rapes are committed against women
and 9
are committed against men and majority
of the time they are being attacked
by a man obviously it's because men are
higher in the trait disagreeableness and
people on the high end of
disagreeableness tend to commit crimes
the
statistics for men being raped is
probably a lot higher because men
are very reluctant to report it and most
people are reluctant to report it anyway
but men are quite reluctant as well
because
of toxic masculinity etc more women are
affected by rape
than men that's what i'm trying to say
i'm not saying that men aren't affected
at all because i know that is but it is
an issue which does affect women
quite a lot i probably say the false
accusation argument
is one of the most common forms of
misogyny
in the 21st century in particular on
social media
and what i mean by this is a lot of
people
in particular men shock when discussions
or conversations
of rape come about which is obviously a
very difficult
topic for people to talk about the first
thing that these people will say is
what about girls who lie and one thing i
just want to say
ladies and gents if you're seeing
someone and this conversation comes up
and the first thing they say is what
about girls or people who lie
run in the other direction huge red flag
zoom
go run just go get out of there also
people who argue this point of what
about girls who lie
it really isn't that much of a
groundbreaking point as you think
it is firstly and a lot of us do know
this rape
is notoriously difficult to get a
conviction
for firstly you need dna evidence and a
lot of people
will not report their assaults
until days months years
after it's happened because they're just
trying to process everything a lot of
people don't realize that they've been
sexually assaulted
until years after it's happened and even
if there is dna evidence
you have to try and prove to a jury
beyond a reasonable doubt that it was a
non-consensual encounter and this is
particularly
difficult to do because the defense can
just say oh well she was consenting
and this is especially difficult to
prove if it started out as a consensual
encounter and then turned
non-consensual not all assaults are
extremely
violent not all assaults leave bruises
marks cuts etc and even if they do
there is something called the rough sex
defense where people can just say
that it was consensual bdsm or rough
kinky no it is hard to get a sexual
assault conviction i what typically they
mean
by what about when they
falsely accuse what they mean is
somebody can fault like a girl can
falsely accuse a guy of rape with
practically no evidence and they can
assassinate his character
and completely and take kick him out of
school whatever
before there's been presented any
evidence and
at the end of the day you either have a
justice system
where you're guilty until proven
innocent or innocent until proven guilty
and that's what they typically mean is
that
you want to make sure they're innocent
until proven guilty sex
and even if there is a lot of evidence
to suggest guilt they still may not be
convicted now i'm going to read this
from my notes because it's quite
difficult to get out
so one example of this being there was a
trial of four
irish rugby players two were found not
guilty of rape and the other two were
cleared of
exposure and perverting the courts of
justice despite there being evidence to
suggest that
all four of them were guilty which ended
up leading to the
i believe her campaign which i will
leave a few links if you guys want to
know more information about it but
examples of this
and failed convictions really put people
off from reporting their assaults in the
first place
so as you can tell from all of these
factors successful
rape convictions are extremely difficult
to come by so to argue that we should
only believe women
once it gets proved in court is
absolutely ridiculous or that the
accuser is a straight-up liar unless it
gets proven in court is again
absolutely ridiculous if you guys didn't
know rape convictions have fallen to an
old time
okay but then how else do you know there
has to be evidence
and you know if somebody tells me
they're sexually assaulted my gut
instinct is to believe them i'm
genuinely a pretty trusting person
but you can't assassinate someone's
character
without evidence like if my brother was
accused of sexual assault or rape
and i know my brother he would never do
something like that
am i gonna automatically believe the
girl who says that
um am i going to want to see evidence
before they convict him or even tell
people at the school that
yeah and i i don't think that's super
controversial
i'm low in england and wales i will just
read out some statistics
between 2019 to 2020 police recorded 55
130 rapes in england and wales but there
was only 2
102 prosecutions so only around 2000
cases
got even taken to court and only 1
439 convictions which means around
98 of rapes that got reported
went with no conviction so because 98
of rapes in england and wales go without
a conviction
does that mean that 98 of people who
reported are liars
of course not absolutely not and another
thing which gets posted on
social media a lot in particular on
twitter and will literally get
tens and thousands of likes and retweets
and it is girls who falsely accuse men
of rape should go to prison
first of all there is such a small
amount of
cases that end up being false
accusations
only around four percent in the uk and
two to six percent
how do you know how could you possibly
know in america and europe
and second of all shouldn't we be
focusing on getting rapists in
prison first being as the death penalty
for rapists
genuinely if you rape someone you should
get the death penalty conviction rate is
only around 2
in england and wales this year why focus
on such a
minor problem and also that it's not
minor
you have no idea how big the problem is
you can't possibly know
how how prevalent that is i'm gonna skip
the rest of this because i'm gonna get
tired
all right empathy
now the last thing i'm going to be
talking about is hymphy i asked you guys
over on
my instagram for what modern forms of
misogyny you have experienced yourself
and a few of you guys actually messaged
me about the term empathy
and in particular how the term hypothese
relates to the tory lanez
megan the stallion situation quick uh
public service announcement i literally
found out the day after i filmed this
that is actually pronounced
tory lanes wow i had no idea i never
listened to his music anyway but uh you
know so i say
tory laynez instead of tory lanez this
entire video which is an extremely
embarrassing moment for me in my career
but anyways enjoy if you guys don't know
the talk she's kind of funny three and
megan's situation
tori laines who's a famous male rapper
shots megan the stallion who is a famous
female rapper
in both of her feet when this incident
first happened
there was no confirmation that tory
lanez actually did it it was just rumors
that was sort of swirling around
and people genuinely wanted to know
whether tori lanez was the person who
shot megan in both of her feet so megan
went on instagram live
and said yes it was tori lanez who shot
me in both of my feeds
now don't get me wrong megan did get an
outpour of
public support like she should she
literally got shot in both of her feet
but she also got a load of criticism
mostly from men shock because apparently
she was being a snitch
or it was people saying that oh there's
two sides to every story
and one thing i want to know if you
think there's two sides to every story
i want to know if there's anything which
makes it justifiable
for a grown ass man to shoot a woman in
both of her feet
did she shoot him first or try to shoot
him i could literally think of one
situation off the top of my head
he was probably in the wrong i'd say i'm
90
certain i can't think of a lot of good
reasons but [ __ ] i can think of one
maybe two please enlighten me let me
know
okay i think that's pretty much it i get
the chest um
this is the hard thing about being a
girl i have to people just assume
that i agree with a lot of this stuff
when i really don't
and in no way am i saying like i have
sympathy for people in bad situations i
have sympathy for babe victims
i have sympathy um you know i think life
isn't fair
and a lot of the stuff she talked about
even like slut-shaming it's not fair
but it is what it is and i'd rather know
the truth than tell the world to change
because people like at least you know
and you don't have to like hide people's
true intentions
if that makes sense but let me know in
the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys
next time